to deliver uh vaccines to places uh
where
they are needed suppose those are the
key areas we could touch on covered of
course
questions likely for mr hancock on
sleaze
on boris johnson's flat but i think
he'll be
trying to focus on the success of the
vaccine program
especially as we're told matt henkel
will get his first dose tomorrow he is
in his
uh early 40s and here we understand
we'll be getting
yeah that first dose tomorrow morning
yeah joe mark austin here just waiting
as you mentioned
uh for the health secretary just coming
up to five o'clock
and the newshour of course so we'll just
carry on chatting while we wait and uh
i presumably when it comes to this whole
issue of uh
boris johnson's issues and the sort of
sleaze allegations swirling around him
presumably ministers will continue to
go out to bat for him i think so matt
hancock is usually
pretty up for doing that and what he can
do
as others have done is point to the fact
that reviews are underway
simon case has a review into the flat
finances law
guide the man announced as the new
advisor to the pm on ministerial
standards former private secretary
to the queen he is also conducting a
review so they can point
to investigations underway of course the
other investigation under a formal
investigation announced this morning is
that the electoral commission
into what happened into the finances uh
they have said they are
have been in contact with the
conservative party for a month
and think potentially there could have
been an offence or a number of
offenses uh committed so clearly a lot
of pressure
on uh boris johnson but if you talk to
people in government what they argue
is that people really care far more
about the success of the vaccine program
which is changing lives changing
livelihoods
than what boris johnson has spent or
rather maybe trying to get other people
to spend
on his flat renovations and they are
hoping
the updates like this evening on the
vaccine possibly
an announcement uh by matt hancock today
that's that's not confirmed we could
have some
announcement that will be what the
public uh care about and hopefully
uh according to conservatives the prime
minister's
private life and private finances won't
for example affect the
local mail or scottish and welsh
elections next thursday
yeah and it's five o'clock uh and uh
this is mark austin with the newshour
we're just waiting for matt hancock to
begin this news conference just a little
bit of breaking news that the uk is
sending
further life-saving life-saving oxygen
equipment to india that includes
three oxygen generation units each
producing
500 liters of oxygen per minute and
uh i'm told the size of shipping
containers so
there was some criticism about the
amount that the uk had sent when it came
to oxygen so more
being sent uh joe pike is with me as we
wait for
matt hancock and of course matt hancock
has not been free of the whole
issue of uh you know covert contracts
and cronyism and so forth
exactly mark because he had contacts and
many people
in the nhs had contacts with david
cameron
and lex green sill and green sill did
get
an nhs uh contract uh eventually after
some of those meetings
so mike hancock of course is what
involved one of the many ministers
officials who seem to have had
uh contact with those uh with that
organization and those two
key characters matt hancock of course
an ally of david cameron when he was uh
prime minister and of george
osborne too but i think matt hancock
perhaps will be pleased
yeah okay joe going to interrupt you uh
matt hancock is about to speak
ronavara's briefing i'm joined by
professor jonathan van tam the deputy
chief medical officer
and dr nikki kanani the medical director
for primary care at
nhs england today we've got an update
in our fight against coronavirus both
here at home
and around the world and i'll i'll start
by talking about events around the world
we've all seen the
harrowing pictures of what's happening
in india
and i think it pains each one of us
who's who's seeing those scenes not
least because the bonds between our
countries are
so strong and they're ties of family
and of friendship i've been in constant
contact with my
indian counterpart and we worked over
the weekend
to put together our first package of
support of ventilators
and oxygen concentrators more supplies
will be arriving
later this week i've also been working
with the health minister for northern
ireland robin swan
to donate large-scale oxygen production
equipment
from northern ireland capable of
producing over a thousand liters of
oxygen per minute
which is one of the main needs of the
people of india
and i'd like to thank robin for the
incredible hard work he's done
in getting this to the position it is so
that we can
get it sent to india where it can
produce that oxygen that's so badly
needed
everyone across this whole united
kingdom
stands side by side with the people of
india in these troubled times
because in this battle against
coronavirus
we're all on the same side this fight is
a global fight
and when other nations face their hour
of need
as we've faced our hour of need here at
home
we'll be there the situation in india
is a stark reminder that this
isn't over yet it shows
how important it is that we are vigilant
here at home and professor
vantam will take us through the data in
a moment but just before we do
i want to give an update on the
vaccination program
this morning we published new data
giving the first
concrete evidence of how much vaccines
reduce transmission within households
we've seen already that a vaccine
reduces your chances of
catching covid by around two-thirds
this new data looked at people who
tested positive
after having received one dose of the
vaccine
and found that they were up to 50
percent
less likely to pass on the disease to
someone else in their household
and we're looking at whether the second
dose gives an
even bigger effect we know that
indoor settings have the highest risk of
transmission so these
results are really encouraging in terms
of the
impact of the vaccine on reducing
transmission
we're finding out more and more about
the different layers of protection
you get from a vaccine and how it's
impacting in the real world
in summary we think that you get around
two-thirds protection from against
catching the disease at all
around four-fifths reduction in your
likelihood
of ending up in hospital and around 85
percent
protection from dying of covid
that's the protection you get from one
dose
and in addition to all that you're up to
half as likely to pass it on to somebody
else that you live with
we expect the benefits to be even
greater after two doses and we're
monitoring that carefully
but what this means is the evidence is
stacking up
that the vaccine protects you it
protects your loved ones
and it is the way out of this pandemic
the overall effectiveness of the
vaccination program
comes from just two things
one how effective the vaccine is that's
the
science if you like and two how many
people
get the jabs and that of course is on
all of us and i just want to turn to the
second of those
for a moment as well this chart
if we have the first animation please
this
shows the proportion of people
who've had the jab according to age
group
and you can see that the green bars
represent the people who've had one dose
and the blue represent people who've had
two and they
are growing over time as the vaccination
program
reaches more and more people who are
younger
and younger and as you can see across
the uk
uptake of the first dose amongst the
over
50s is phenomenally high
at over 95 percent and is rising
sharply in people in their late 40s
who've been
now able to receive the the vaccine for
a couple of weeks
this is great progress and it's
something we can all celebrate because
we all have a part to play in this
and i'm delighted that we've been able
to offer the vaccine now to even more
people
so anyone who is 42 or
older can now come forward and get the
jab
i'm delighted about this uh because it
shows the great progress that we're
making
and i'm also delighted because it means
i can get my jab too
just like every other 42 year old and 43
year old
i got a text from the nhs yesterday
i went online i booked it for myself
it takes less than a minute and i'm
looking forward to getting my jab
first thing tomorrow morning in the
words of our
new campaign every vaccination
brings us hope so we've looked at the
effectiveness of the vaccine
and we've looked at the take up of the
vaccine now i want to turn to the
combination of the two
what i'm about to show you is not how
many people have had the jab
but how many people have got the
antibodies
that that that make the jab effective
these antibodies that protect you from
coronavirus
this isn't a measure of the vaccination
program directly
this is a measure of the protection that
we have
collectively built up in people right
across the country
if we can have the the second chart
please this data
released today by the office for
national statistics
is from the a national survey where they
visit
over 20 000 people and they actually
measure the antibodies in people's
bloodstreams
the blue area shows the proportion of
people who have covered 19
antibodies as you can see the in the
older age groups
those who got vaccinated first they are
much more likely to have
covid19 antibodies so more and more
people
are getting protection and now seven in
ten adults
have protective covered antibodies
this is the vaccination program in
action
and it makes me so proud of what we've
done
we have been working on the vaccine
program for more than a year now
there's a massive team to it and i'm
very very grateful to them all
but the thing that makes me proudest is
how
when the call came the whole nation
who's been
asked has effectively stepped forward
because this vaccination program depends
yes on the effectiveness of the science
and that is crucial but it depends on
everybody stepping forward
the vaccine is helping us to bring back
our freedom and we must protect this
progress
the biggest risk to that progress is the
risk
posed by a new variant so we're working
on our plans for booster shots too and
this is the final thing i want to
talk about to keep us safe
and free here while we get this disease
under control
across the whole world we have been
working
on a program of booster shots again for
over a year now and we've backed some
of the only clinical trials in the world
looking specifically
at booster shots i'm delighted to be
able to tell you
that we've secured a further 60 million
doses of the pfizer beyond tech vaccine
that will be used alongside others as
part of our booster shop program
later this year and that is
all about protecting the progress that
we've made
we have a clear route out of this crisis
but this is no time
for complacency it's a time for caution
so we can keep the virus under control
while we take the steps
safely back to normal life so please
remember that
the basics of hands face space and fresh
air
and crucially if
like me you get the call
join me and get the jab i'd now like to
hand over to professor van tam to talk
through the latest data
and then dr canaani to talk through
some of the detailed data about that
extraordinarily high take-up of the
vaccine
professor thank you secretary of state
good afternoon i'm going to
just spend the first few minutes going
through four
data slides which show you where we are
and the state of play in the uk
at the moment and then on the fifth
slide
i will just um talk in a little more
detail
about the new data that have been uh
published in pre-print form
uh by uh scientific colleagues from
public health england
this morning and relating to vaccine
related reductions in transmission
inside households first slide please
so these slides are familiar it's a
little while since i've
presented them to you but you can see
the
this is an array of people numbers of
people testing positive
for covert 19 in the uk from first of
september on the left
through to late april on the right very
visible indeed
is that very large third wave that we
had
peaking in mid-january and you can see
now that we are
really in very low levels that are
comparable
to where we were in september last year
um we're running as a typical seven day
average
just over 2 000 people testing positive
per day my sense is that probably we are
at or close to the bottom at the moment
in terms of
this level of disease in the uk next
slide please
on slide number two it's the same time
scale
but this time i'm arraying the number of
people in hospital
with kovid 19 in the uk and again the
the pattern is the same this very large
and really quite serious third wave that
we had
and now we are i think close to the
bottom
but probably we will find there's a
little further to run
in terms of reductions in the total
number of people
in hospital in the uk with covid
and on the 26th of april that was 1600
people next slide please
turning now unfortunately to deaths
you can see the size of the third
peak in the third wave in the uk
compared with the first peak high seven
day rolling average that's that
horizontal
blue line that goes mid-way across
across the chart
but thankfully you can see that we are
now down in the last seven days to an
average of
22 deaths per day related to covid
still regrettable of course
in terms of deaths that we wish weren't
happening
but obviously in a very different place
to where we were in those dark
first few weeks of 2021 next slide
please
now you'll notice here that
before i even talk about the data i want
to talk about the
time scales along the bottom you can see
that this slide is arrayed from the 10th
of january
until late april and it's an array of
the number of people
who have received a vaccination for
covert in the uk
so it's essentially a static
representation
of the movie that you sure you saw just
a while ago
but importantly i want to draw your
attention
to where the peak of the third wave
would appear on this slide and it would
appear
shall we say around the 24th of january
which is visible to you on there
and you can see at that point we didn't
really have very many people vaccinated
at all
and so i have to say it and it is only
epidemiologically true to say it
that most of the steady decline we have
seen
the disappearance of our third wave
has been down to the efforts of the
british people
in following lockdown now the vaccine
has undoubtedly helped in the later
stages
and there's good evidence that the death
rate in the elderly has dropped
faster than it has in the younger age
groups
and it's dropped faster than it did in
the second wave
and that is undoubtedly a vaccine effect
but what is really important about these
vaccines
and about the vaccine rollout that
it really is the way out of getting into
trouble
of the same size and magnitude ever
again
and that's why it's important that this
job must get finished
next slide please and in terms of
finishing the job we now have
i think some quite solid data on
the way in which vaccine can cut
household transmission
now this is a study called the hosted
study from
public health england colleagues and
the estimates it's a very big study um
365 000 households over a million
contacts within those households and the
study was about
vaccinated people who in spite of the
one dose of vaccine
still got covered symptoms and still
tested positive
in other words you do get some people
who get covered
even though they've had one dose of
vaccine but
this study also looked at their
unvaccinated
household contacts and
could show that with both vaccines you
can see the range of
of the range of estimates on these blue
circles
that there is a substantial reduction
in creating further cases
who also had symptoms and tested
positive
for coronavirus in those households
the point estimate for azad is
38 and the point estimate for pfizer
is 49 but really those ranges are rather
more important
illustrating even despite that massive
size of the study the uncertainties in
the data
and the fact that both are doing an
extremely good job
in reducing household transmission and
that's after
one dose so i do expect these to be
these results to improve after two doses
and the other thing i should say is that
the estimates are probably conservative
because if you get two members of a
household
who actually both pick up coronavirus
from
the same visitor at the door or the same
place they went to wherever it was and
their incubation periods are different
one had a short incubation period
they're the index case
and one the household contact had a
longer
incubation period then actually
you would say that the second one was a
contact of the first and that
transmission had occurred
between them but in actual fact they may
have got it
from the same place in the first
instance so there will be some of that
in the study
and therefore i think these are quite
cautious
estimates of how important these
vaccines are going to be
in reducing transmission and remember
that a second dose should improve the
situation further
i'm going to stop there thank you
secretary of state thank you very much
professor
van tam i'm now going to turn to dr
konani thank you
um so let me begin by giving my thanks
my heartfelt thanks to colleagues around
the country
who are still absolutely knocking it out
of the park making sure that people are
getting protected
and i want to congratulate particularly
uh satya and her team from medway
who have achieved 50 000 vaccinations
this week
and sarah and her team from harrogate
and rural who have achieved a hundred
thousand
vaccines given uh this week as well
really quite phenomenal
and in the last week since i was last
here the nhs in
england has managed to vaccinate 3.3
million people with a first or second
dose so that is nearly 28 and a half
million people in england who have had
their first dose
and over 11.4 million people who have
had their second dose
and that second dose as you heard is
crucial that is where
we are getting protection but we still
have to follow
social distancing guidance and that's
really key
but that means that we have now
vaccinated nearly two-thirds of the
adult population in england
and more than a quarter of people have
been fully
vaccinated as i said it's important that
we all keep following national advice to
reduce transmission
hospital admissions and deaths from
covert 19.
but i'm pleased and i'm encouraged to
see that we're keeping up the momentum
and that we're on track in the biggest
vaccination program
that the nhs has ever coordinated
i'm particularly proud a secretary of
state mentioned that we opened our
booking lines to 44 year olds on monday
and 43 and 42 year olds yesterday
nearly three-quarters of a million
people booked their appointments from
monday alone
so that is nearly 250 appointments
booked a minute
or around 15 000 an hour it's incredible
progress
and will continue to maintain that as
far as supplies allow
so my message to everyone watching is
the same as last week
if you're invited to get a vaccine
whether it's your first or second dose
please come forward if you need to get a
test
or you're asked to get a test please
come forward
and if you have a health concern please
also come forward
because your nhs is still there for you
thank you
thank you very much dr kanani we're now
going to questions from the public
before some questions from journalists
and the first
question from a member of the public is
from rachel in derby by
video my question is
when will we be able to take our care
home relatives
outside for a walk in the fresh air
without them having to self-isolate
on their return it's been almost 14
months
since my mom has been able to leave the
premises
and her condition has deteriorated she's
now also
on antidepressants please help us find
a safe way for this to happen very soon
thank you thank you rachel it's an
incredibly important question
and we are working on it right now
and in fact i had a meeting on this
yesterday to
make sure that we can get the rules
right so that people can
safely leave a care home and come back
without bringing coronavirus back into
the home
and especially now that vaccinations
have
taken place amongst residents
the vast vast majority have now had two
doses
and and amongst staff vaccination rates
are rising
as well and also because the rates of
coronavirus
are so much lower in the community so i
hope that we can have some good news for
you
soon rachel you'll understand given the
history why it's so important that we
have
protective rules for those who live in
care homes they are amongst the most
vulnerable
to covid but we also know that there are
there are that there are risks and
health consequences
of not having visitors and not allowing
care home residents to visit out without
as you say having then
to isolate within the home uh when they
come back so i hope some good news
for you soon is there anything you'd
like to add i i only really want to
you know echo what the secretary of
state has said that
you know this is desperately important
for people's mental health
and desperately important that we do
restore that normality for people who
live
in residential care but it has to be
done carefully and
the additional science factor is that we
still need further data
to understand with a little more clarity
whether
these vaccines work as well in the
extremely frail elderly
as they do in the fit and younger
adult and we need to know if they work
as well
in patients who are clinically
vulnerable
or clinically extremely vulnerable with
underlying conditions
those data are going to take a little
while longer to give us real clarity
and they will help us pull this picture
together
so i hope we can move with maximum safe
speed to get back to normal
thanks very much the next question is
from
a melanie in derbyshire by text
and melanie asks during the pandemic
the uk has emerged as a powerhouse of
biomedical research
innovation and development what plans
does the government have to
continue this beyond covid and make the
uk
a global leader in this area melanie
this is an incredibly important question
and in fact after being vaccinated
tomorrow morning i'm then going to give
a speech on precisely this topic so
you've asked it at a very good
moment the truth is in my view and i'll
ask
the i'll ask the scientific view uh in a
moment the truth is
that in this pandemic the uk
life sciences and biomedical
research have given a huge amount to the
world
probably our greatest contribution to
saving lives and
tackling this pandemic around the world
is the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine and in particular the decision
to ensure that it's provided
at cost without any charge for
profit or intellectual property it's
been a
a huge and heroic effort and i am very
grateful
to the team at oxford and the team at
astrazeneca who've done
an absolutely amazing job at making this
happen
and then the capabilities for instance
in
in clinical trials because it's in the
uk clinical trials that we've discovered
the most
drugs that work to save people's lives
first of course dexter methods and which
they estimate
has saved up to a million lives around
the world already
and to make sure that this is a very
successful going forward
we're going to ensure that we attract
onshore here in the uk not just the
research
the innovation the development that you
mentioned but also the manufacturing
of these products we want to make it
impor an
impossible choice for a
pharmaceutical company to not to invest
in the uk
and one of our commitments is that we
will not
ever block exports to anywhere around
the world of a product made
from for a market around the world
so you might have noticed you struck a
chord
with your question it's something i care
deeply about there's a huge amount for
the
uk and that the uk can help
collaboratively
working with others around the world uh
to uh
to to save and improve lives not just in
terms of covert in this pandemic
but the many many other things we need
to do in the future tackling cancer
research for dementia so many other
uh vital things that we need to do yeah
dr khan
thank you i mean i think one of the
things melanie that it's worth
reflecting on is the
anti-viral task force that we talked
about last week
um the nhs has taken a leading role in
identifying different treatments for
kovid
so secretary of state mentioned the
million
lives saved worldwide it's estimated by
the use of dexamethasone
that's 22 000 lives probably saved by
dexamethasone in the uk alone
so um a part of that is thanks to the
1.1 million people
who have engaged in research so one of
my pleas is keep engaging in research
because actually
with your help we can continue to be a
global leader
and remember that we are now taking
therapies uh from
theory into the front line within six
days
so it's really important that we
continue the research keep learning and
keep showing the country what we can do
absolutely professor i'm extremely proud
of the uk
um science showing in this awful
pandemic
i particularly want to thank the
national institute for health
research the nihr who've been the
absolute backbone
of everything that we've done and i want
to thank nhs
frontline clinicians who somehow have
fitted in the consenting and recruiting
of patients into these massive studies
alongside this appalling workload that
they've had and i want to thank the
patients
you know tens of thousands of them
across the uk
who've in that you know despite being
very ill with coronavirus
who've said yeah clinical trial i'm up
for it
sign me up and that's really quite
remarkable
and um i want to remind you that still
going on we are the ones
who are trying to generate the data
on mix and match schedules for vaccines
we are the ones that are already very
deep in planning
to understand vaccine studies to look at
booster doses for vaccines
either for the autumn or for later if
later is when they are needed
but all of that work is going on and
multiple countries and organizations
around the world
are constantly asking and saying
wow you know you're getting on with that
already when can you share the data with
us so
yeah we're in a good place on the
science
thanks very much melanie for your
question incredibly important
for the future and uh something that we
all care very very
much about the next question is from
laura koonsberg at the
at the bbc thank you very much secretary
of state
um if a serving government minister is
found to have broken the rules on party
funding
or even law should they resign
well thanks very much i know that the
prime minister answered
lots of questions about this in the
house of commons earlier
and given that this is a coronavirus
press conference you won't be surprised
that i'm not going to add to the
answers the prime minister's already
given to very extensive questioning
thanks
next question is christian gurimurthy
mr hancock i want to come to the
situation in india which is distressing
millions of people
in this country as well i'm sure the
oxygen will be appreciated by the
hundreds it will save but
india has a shortage of vaccines not
least because
america has restricted the export of
components
even though india kept ingredients going
the other way are you reconsidering
britain's
sort of britain first approach to
vaccines um and considering whether you
can release any doses
to help india um and also are you as
edward lee suggested today perhaps
reconsidering the
the drastic cuts to the international
development budget
which could also have drastic impact on
the impact of covert in the world's
poorest countries well
as you say christian we are supporting
india with what we can and we don't have
any excess doses
of vaccine in the uk at the moment but
what we have done
is by providing the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
at cost and working with the serum
institute of
india they are making
and producing more doses of vaccine than
any other
single organization and
obviously that means that they can
provide vaccine
to people in india at cost
with the investment that we put in here
to get that vaccine up and running so
fast so
absolutely we're leaning in uh both on
what we can provide and the material
goods we can provide
now like ventilators that we thankfully
don't need
anymore here and we're sending them over
and like the
the oxygen production machines
which are being sent over from northern
ireland
but also it is the it is the vaccine
and the ability the deal that was done
so that india can
produce its own vaccine based on uh
british technology that is uh that is
the biggest contribution that we can
make which effectively comes
from british science thanks very much
next question
ben kentish at lbc
thank you secretary uh given what you
and professor van tam have said today
about how positive the data is looking
given almost 70 percent of adults in
england now have antibodies
i wanted to ask about the rules and
particularly about funerals because some
say there is a risk
that you are now doing exactly what you
said you wouldn't
and sticking rigidly to date set back in
february rather than factoring and
how good the data is looking now there's
rules in all sorts of areas but we've
heard so many stories from people
who cannot mourn loved ones in the way
they would wish
given in seven weeks time those same
people will be able to pack into
nightclubs
will you look again at relaxing the
rules on funerals and if i could just
ask you a second question
about a month ago you said in a few
weeks we'd have data
on how well current vaccines are working
against current variants could you tell
us what that data shows and what it
means for
both international travel this summer
but also the need or otherwise for a
booster program
uh this autumn and if i could just go
ask a very cheeky quick one to professor
van tan
given that antibody data professor how
close do you think we are
to herd immunity and what sort of
threshold would we be looking at
in percentage terms in order to reach
that thank you very much
thanks very much ben so i'll ask uh
professor vantam to answer the second
and the third question if i may
if you don't mind the extra burden on
your workload um
the um on on funerals um this is of
course incredibly important and very
uh a very sensitive subject
the data show that we are essentially
precisely on track for where we expected
to be at this point
and that is obviously good news it means
that we can follow the roadmap
and we look at the data all of the time
the dates that we set out are not before
dates
because we want to see the impact of
each step
before the decision to take the next
step so that's why the roadmap's been
structured the way that it is
so that we can check that we are on
track
the good news is that as far as the next
step is concerned which is in a few
weeks time and we're going to keep
monitoring the data
but as of today we are on track for step
three
on the 17th of may and that is good news
we're almost exactly where the modelers
predicted that we would be
at this point on questions two and three
yeah thanks thanks ben
i think there are some twists and turns
ahead still
but i think we are moving at pace and i
think we're essentially following
a good dry line now but i don't want us
to run into any wet patches
that is going to be really critical in
the next few weeks
there are going to be good pressures on
our
and bad pressures on our in the next few
weeks
obviously with the 17th of may planned
easements
and the 21st of june planned easements
these will have a propensity as we mix
more and more normally
to increase r at the same time
we hope that the continued vaccine
rollout
if it continues as well as it has
started
will put the downward pressure on r
so those are kind of competing forces
that are at play
in the next few weeks for all the right
reasons
and so i want us to continue
at pace but still with caution
and i can't emphasize how important
the vaccine program continues to be
because we are at the moment down to 42
year olds
but we need to go much further down
and continue that high uptake to put us
in a really
sustainably safe place now on the
variance which was your next question
all of the data that you've heard at
previous
press briefings and the data again today
are
largely generated after christmas
and because they are largely generated
after christmas
they are generated against the kent
b117 variant virus and so we are
extremely confident that um our current
vaccines are working extremely well
against the dominant variant in the uk
there are now other variants and of
course there's
ones that are in the headlines such as
the the indian 617 variant
and there are others which have been in
the headlines for some time
such as the south african 351 variant
and the brazil p1 those
case numbers in the uk have grown
um i couldn't call the numbers trivial
but at the same token i don't see them
rushing away
now or in the next few weeks in terms of
giving as a
new kind of problem the way you test the
vaccines against these variants
is either you have that variant
circulating widely in your population
and then you kind of learn the hard way
whether the vaccines are working or not
you gain real life epidemiological data
we can't do that if they're not
circulating
we're trying not to let them circulate
so we're not going to create that
situation
so instead what we do are a series of
laboratory studies
called neutralization studies and what
they do is they
take blood with antibodies from people
who've had the vaccine
and we can run that blood that serum
against a range of different viruses
and if the antibodies neutralize the
virus
that tells us that the vaccines are
likely
to work well if
the antibodies don't fully neutralize
the virus
that unfortunately doesn't tell us the
opposite because we know vaccines not
only stimulate the production of
antibodies
they stimulate t cell immunity which you
can't measure in that same way and so
what i'd say at the moment is that we do
see
that as we go from kent
to south africa to to brazil and then to
south africa
that we do see the level of
neutralization
fall somewhat against the current
vaccines
but we can't say without those real
epidemiological data
what the true clinical impact will be
likely in my view the first thing to go
if something goes will be protecting
against infection
but i hope protection against severe
disease
will be much more solid and much more
lasting
but it is an uncertain world i'm not
going to give you a kind of false
reassurance in this space
and that is why and it is somebody
reminded me
um today that it was a year ago when i
first sent an
email about this to the secretary of
state apparently
and um
it is why we have always framed this
in terms of potentially the need to
re-vaccinate our population
or at least parts of it at some point in
the future
and not yet precisely known and not yet
precisely known who
and possibly with variant vaccines
but again not precisely known and partly
dependent upon what the manufacturers
can give to us so
that's a long answer but i hope it's a
complete one and i hope
it gives you a sense that there is
scientific uncertainty
but we are watching this and have been
for quite some time
fantastic great questions ben and that
answer
is why he's a professor um
the um the the i'm just gonna have one
thing
on the policy consequences of that
um the challenges around international
travel are around essentially around
uncertainty
and that's why policy making around
international travel
is so difficult we need to protect the
progress that we've made
through combination of the robust
measures we have in place at the border
and booster jabs later
in the year and that is all about
protecting the progress
that is made so far and we have and we
do that learning as much as we can
whenever the science uh can come up with
that data
thanks very much indeed uh chris smith
at the times
thank you just to clarify on these new
files of doses will they be tweaked to
target new variants um
and if not given we've already got
enough doses on order to vaccinate the
population
three times over why do we need them and
shouldn't we be giving them to india or
other countries
in desperate need um and you talked
about the
the modeling last week sage police
estimates suggesting that even after
vaccinating all adults
it's unlikely possible to go back to
normal uh pre-pandemic levels
of social contact without cases rising
again so
professor antam what kind of measures do
you think might be necessary beyond the
road map
and secretary of state you know are
fresh coronavirus restrictions something
the government is considering after june
the 21st
or can you rule out any legal limits um
on social interaction
beyond this point if i if i can uh
suspect i know the answer follow up
laura's question
last year amanda milling trying to
abolish the electoral commission if it
didn't
do the job that ministers wanted to as
it now investigates the prime minister
and the conservative party is it doing
so with that threat still hanging over
it
um so i'll answer the first question and
then ask
jbt to answer the second question um and
i think we'll give the third one a miss
um the um the truth is
uh that with the 60 million pfizer jabs
don't yet
they have not yet been manufactured this
is a forward order so it's not that
they are uh there now in our uh phe
freezers uh ready to roll out
um and i'll ask jvt to set out the
uh the uh the the science
behind how you'd give one vaccine and
then a different vaccine in order to
give people that
uh protection including against a
new uh variant um but the
uh the situation in terms of um
of india is that the they
obviously have a vaccination program
which is largely driven
by the oxford astrazeneca vaccine that's
being produced
in india and we obviously work very
closely with them
to ensure that they have access to that
vaccine
and at cost and you'll see that around
the rest of the world there's this big
debate about whether
the intellectual property of the some of
the other vaccines should be
should be waived um because of the extra
um cost that it adds and we of course
have done that from the start
for the period of the pandemic from the
astrazeneca
oxford uh vaccine and it's something
that i'm
i'm very very proud of um the um on
on your second question i just want to
make this point which is that
the vaccine breaks the link from cases
to hospitalizations and deaths
it also we now know reduces your
likelihood of transmitting the disease
too
so it has a downward impact on r and it
also breaks the link
so we no longer look at cases as
an inevitable precursor to future
hospitalizations and deaths
that was a reasonable rule of thumb
throughout the autumn
and sadly came to be true as the charts
that uh we showed earlier
uh demonstrate that is no longer the
case
so we're going to have to live with
coronavirus
much like we do with flu and wrestling
covert 19
to the position that it is rather like
flu
it's something we do things about like
infection prevention control
in hospitals like vaccination which
we've done for
flu for 40 years and but it isn't
something that dominates our lives
as it does today that is the
strategic goal if you like and obviously
the vaccination program is absolutely
central to it professor
yeah chris thanks for the questions if
if you can spare the time then i'll kind
of tell you a bit more
um we have a whole cohort of people
across the uk
who by late summer by perhaps by me
somehow i will have had
astrazeneca astrazeneca as their two
days primary course
or fisa pfizer as their two-dose primary
course
the question then scientifically is if
you need to boost those people
at some point in the autumn or the
winter what do you give them
do you give them the same again or do
you give them something different
and there's a study that will start in
june called cov
boost and it's professor faust and
professor snape
are going to be running this it will be
available to many many people across the
uk because
so many of us would have had um a course
of vaccines by then
and people will be invited and
randomized
to different kinds of vaccines as the
booster
and we'll get an idea then of
which give you the highest boost which
perhaps give you the broadest boost
against a range of coronavirus variants
and indeed
what the kind of timings look like on
that and
that is another reason why the vaccines
task force
has invested in contracts with not just
one or two manufacturers
but six or seven so that we have that
optionality
so we can always try and do the very
best thing
scientifically within the constraints of
what we can
realize in terms of supply at the time
so that's the kind of answer and why
it's not straightforward
and why there are you know a number of
important
insurance decisions around optionality
of different supplies of vaccine
for the autumn it's not as simple as
cases just counting up the heads in the
uk and going well
you've got too much it may be more
subtle than that
on measures beyond the road map i think
the modeling consensus is clear that
we will have what is called a third wave
i am
personally hopeful that if the vaccine
program continues at pace and continues
to be as successful as it's been
the third wave so to speak might just be
a third upsurge and
much less significant because of the
de-linking
of cases to hospitalizations and deaths
as the secretary of state has accurately
said but i think it's
inconceivable to think that we would go
from
a period of relative calm which we which
is where we are now with no further
bumps in the road
in terms of upswings in activity between
now and this time next year and so i am
anticipating
um some degree of bumpiness
um probably in the in the autumn and the
winter
but really it's impossible to say and so
much depends
upon first of all the success of our
vaccine program
not just what we've done already but
what we have to do in terms of finishing
the job
and getting down to the youngest adults
and secondly in terms of what the
variance will bring us
which is very largely a biological
unknown at this point
thank you thanks very much indeed next
question ben glaze
at the mirror uh thank you secretary of
state
um we've got various inquiries now into
lobbying and leaks and loans but what we
haven't got is an inquiry into the
pandemic
which has killed 127 000 people in this
country
and grieving relatives say that with
them case rates low and deaths
of continuing to fall the time is right
um for you to set a timetable for that
inquiry can you offer them
some comfort tonight and set out a
timetable
and to professor van tam and
what sort of issues do you think what
aspects of the
response do you think our public inquiry
should examine
and then just one additional uh question
a few secretaries say if that's okay
um as a former culture as culture
secretary you uh championed the rights
of the free press and the fourth estate
to ask
difficult questions uh yet this evening
you haven't engaged with those questions
from chris or from laura
around tori sleeves now what's the point
of us being able to ask difficult
questions
if you're not going to engage with them
thanks well on the last one
the point of the press conference is the
incredibly important progress that we're
making about coronavirus
which is without doubt the most
important thing facing the country
and if you've listened to the answers
i'm sure you have from dr kanani and
professor van tan
you'll have had one of the most
illuminating descriptions of where we're
up to
scientifically and operationally and
clinically
that is available and i'm very very
grateful to the
uh incredible uh capability of the
people who support me
as a minister and as i say it is
important uh
that there are questions and there were
endless questions in the house of
commons
earlier on the on the some of the issues
that you raised and you'll have seen the
appointment of lord
gate earlier but you've also got to
concentrate on the
on the big things that really matter on
the
point about an inquiry you're quite
right that it's important that we have
an inquiry um and um it's important too
that we learn lessons all of the time
um and i think that it is
vital that we that we
constantly are seeking to learn what we
can about the science about how the
rollout's working
about how we can improve policy and then
respond to that um and um
and so there will be time uh for an
inquiry uh
but the uh the most important thing for
the the
the the decision makers um is to make
sure that we're constantly learning
and on what that inquiry might cover
i don't know whether you want to add
anything my view is it should cover it
you should cover everything i mean
that's the
that's the point you heard from uh
jonathan van tam just now that
he emailed me more than a year ago to
talk about booster shots
you know i think that shows great
foresight uh and i'm sure there'll be
lots of other things like that
uh that will be considered in the
inquiry doctor yes i mean i think i
think that's right we need to cover um
everything ben
that's exactly what should happen um to
make sure that we are thorough
um but i want to at the same time make
sure we focus on
what the vaccination program is doing
and my message will
continue to be keep coming forward for
the vaccination
when you're offered to do so and if the
vaccination is part of that inquiry we
will make sure
that we keep learning from that and use
that learning in booster programs and
and going forward as well anything to
add
yes something to our thanks secretary of
state so look um
my views on the inquiry are it's very
important but please not now
we are far too busy still engaged in
cementing in
the gains that we've made and making
sure that we don't
have anything like the same kind of
turbulence
next winter as we had this winter
i hope the inquiry will focus very
strongly
on the amazing success of the vaccine
procurement and vaccine delivery i was
out
earlier this week in my hometown of
boston
with the team with linda and her team at
the
princess royal arena one of the mass
vaccination centers
and um you know
they are doing a brilliant job and each
one of them should be able to
look back and look at themselves in the
mirror
in the future and say this is what i did
in 2021 this is the difference i made
and i think that's really important and
i hope that the inquiry properly
explores the role of the unsung heroes
at the local level
who just one by one day by day
hour by hour and never tiring
of vaccinating the people of this
country
fantastic maybe they'll see themselves
not only in the mirror but also in
her majesty's mirror who knows thanks
very much
ben next question david hughes from pa
uh one for all of you in america the
health regulators have said the latest
science means
people who have received both doses of
the vaccine can meet up freely
um if the government's still guided by
the science why can't that happen here
is it because as phd's mary ramsey said
today
there are different cultural
perspectives and there's a desire for
everyone to move at once here and for
you secretary of state
um you often find yourself on a
different side of the arguments to the
prime minister during uh
consideration of lockdowns did you ever
hear him say that he'd be prepared to
let coronavirus rip or see bodies pile
up rather than impose another lockdown
no i didn't uh and uh on the first
question
um the um
the decision we've taken and i think
it's a decision very widely supported
across the country
is to move together and that's what
the roadmap does as you know in the
autumn
we move different parts of the country
different parts of
england according to the the rates that
we saw
in those areas that had some advantages
but it also had a disadvantage that we
then saw in the areas where we had fear
restrictions we saw cases
uh pop up so we took the decision when
we
uh when we wrote the road map to that we
all
uh move as one and i think that that is
very very
widely supported professor and then
we'll end with
uh dr kunani so just a bit of science on
the
vaccinated people meeting you are quite
right
that if two people who've had both had
two doses of vaccine
and have both um served if that's the
right term
at least 14 days after their second
dose then i would be highly confident
scientifically that if those were
reputable vaccines
then indeed it would be incredibly safe
for those two people to meet so
the answer to your question though is
soon
i really hope soon but not
quite now please remember that nobody
under 42
other than the clinically extremely
vulnerable in whom the vaccine may be
slightly less effective
and healthcare workers have had the
vaccine
let alone had two courses and been 14
days beyond it
so i know this feels tantalizingly
extremely close and it is
going to be frustrating at times for
people
particularly those who've had their two
doses but
um we just need to make sure we don't
have to go
backwards again on any of this and just
kind of you know
just hold the line for just a teeny bit
longer
not all 42 year olds have had it yet um
dr cannani thank you um thanks david i
think one of the things that is really
worth reflecting on
as we talk about moving as a country
together is that the vaccination program
has
really at its core always talked about
not leaving people behind
and so it's really important that we
have vaccine equity i spoke
last week about uptake in ethnic
minority groups um
rising at a at a exponential rate and we
need to make sure that
everyone is protected because um and
you've heard it before
but none of us are protected until all
of us are protected
so a little bit longer please thanks
very much
that brings this coronavirus briefing to
an end
hope to see you soon
there we are matt hancock wrapping up
the news conference a lot about india
the importance of standing side by side
with the people of
india said matt hancock also a lot about
vaccines
and he was saying that seven in 10
adults
in the uk have protective antibodies
also saying the uk has secured 60
million more
fisa doses for a booster program
jonathan van tam
talking about the road ahead said he
anticipated some bumpiness
maybe in autumn and winter he said a
third wave
might be just a third up surge and on
the issue of
boris johnson and funding for his flat
uh well they steered
very clear of that let's talk to our
health correspondent ashish joshi
and ashi so as i say a lot about
india and new help for india and also a
lot about vaccines
yeah i think he had to address the india
situation first and foremost there has
been a lot of criticism
of the british government and the aid
that it has offered to india
particularly at this time so he was
talking about oxygen generating machines
which he's procured which will
be dispatched india that will address
the immediate concerns there but after
that
it was positive data after positive data
that was a very long press conference
and the reason for that is because they
wanted to present all
the the positive strides that this
vaccination program
continues to make they were talking
about the uptake being very high
and the impact it's had on debts and
hospitalization so everything they had
to say
was really good news they were talking
about rolling out to the next
cohorts of uh anyone who's 42 years old
and above and
the health secretary himself saying that
he would be getting his vaccination
first thing tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m
so he was really upbeat you you saw him
smile throughout that press conference
and that hasn't happened mark
for a very very long time and
there was of course um a tempering
of the good news jonathan van tan
reminding us all
that it was because of the monumental
effort not just of the vaccine program
but also the efforts of the british
public in making sure that they adhered
to lockdown restrictions and that
is why we are heading very smoothly at
the moment
towards the the may the 17th and the
the uh the june targets as well that all
looks like that's very achievable given
the data that's been presented today
we were talking about the one particular
report today that they referred to in
this
press briefing was about the impact the
vaccine has on transmission and that's
crucial we know the vaccine
will protect us from infection but now
we have good data
showing us just how effective it is at
protecting
um other people from getting the the
coronavirus because it lowers
transmission so much
and that's what jonathan van tan was
keen to say but also
saying that if there is an inevitable
third wave which the data and the
modeling suggested will be
with the vaccine program working as well
as it is right now
that shouldn't be more than an upsurge
okay ashish thank you very much
indeed this is the
newshour at six o'clock or just after
six o'clock now coming up
arlene foster announces she's to stand
down as first minister of northern
ireland and as leader of the dep
are you worried about the investigation
prime minister
who cocked up for the flexer the prime
minister
under attack and now under investigation
over the refurbishment of his downing
street flat
this is what we're finding lots of small
shots selling oxygen and when they're
open and when they have oxygen
they're packed as india passes a grim
milestone
of two hundred thousand deaths i'll be
asking the government in delhi how the
crisis spiraled
out of